Hey hows it going bros
My name is Pew-
[Fake PewDiePie]: PewDiePie
What!
[Fake PewDiePie]: Please
What do you want? Stop
[Fake PewDiePie]: Hey PewDiePie
I'm doing my intro
This is my show
How's it going-
[Fake PewDiePie]: Please please please
Shut the fuck up -_-
no, no :'((
[Fake PewDiePie]: It's super cool
Okay no I'm not turning around
There's only two things in the world
That would make me turn around,
and look what's behind me
Number 1,
Donald Trump's penis.
Number 2,
a fuckin' toad
Well, well, well.
Felix.
*Dramatic music starts*
Look what we have here.
Today is your lucky day.
A toad.
*lightning strike sound effect*
YOU GOT A TOAD?
YOU GOT A TOAD???
OH
THAT'S AMAZING
Thank you fake PewDiePie
come here
*fake pewdiepie is in ceaseless agony*
wait
wait fake pewdiepie
Can you - could you film this for me
I wanna interact with the toad
Thank you fake Felix.
for give-
You know how heartbroken I was...
when Ainsley left me...
*sad music*
A toad...
Thank you
Now I'm not fucking touching that shit though
[Fake PewDiePie / Camera Man]: touch it you faggot
no you touch it
[Fake PewDiePie / Camera Man]: no no no no no no no
*Pewds laughs* (Then) *sighs*
Okay fine
I'll play with slippy
Alright guys, we bought a toad.
I don't know why
I think this is a terrible idea
but he's in here
His name is Slippy
I've never touched him before
Uh... I wanna be gentle
and make sure...
Slippy...
Is he there? Is he there?
heyy!
okay
alright
I'm terrified of this toad.
I'm legit scared of even looking at it.
cause you don't know-
It looks calm right now.
Alright?
It could- Slippy could attack.
At any moment.
*BREATHE*
Why am I such a fucking pussy?
He looks calm..
But he's also-
oh
You see that? he moved, he's a little scared
He will attack
[Camera Man]: He looks like the big mean toad
[Camera Man]: from Naruto
*Action music*
*Inaudible*
Oh, jesus-- I'm so fucking scared
I'm such a pussy!
Jesus
hey slippy how you doing slippy
let me just say hello to you slippy
Oh.
Hey, how you doin', Slippy?
He's smelling me
Look at his nose
hey slippy
He feels like sandpaper, a li'l bit
oh my god
Why am-
eugh
*laugh*
what- I'm not scared, okay? (yes you are)
I'm not scared
You think I'm scared?
Look- look I'm not scared at all
oh god
*dramatic/tense music*
hey slippy
would you mind if i touched you? (plz no)
come here
*Dramatic music rises*
Ooo!
he's nice!
hey
He's pretty chill actually
oh
hey don't jump in- Slippy don't kill yourself :((
Look at him (slippy trying to break free)
Hey Slippy
ok, he's calm
Good boy
good boy slippy
good boy, He's cool!
I never hold one before
So this is a cane toad,
They can get huge
and they live for like.. 10 to 15 years?
OH
Hey! *Slippy hops away*
SLIPPY
It's like holding a cheeseburger, *laughs* it's really it
It's really weird
They do bite, they have a really strong jaw
So I.. wanna be careful
But he's pretty chill
I like him
This is cool
How you doing Slippy-kun?
I faced my fear today guys
So we're gonna give Slippy a voice
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
He's really cool
why did you get a toad?
cause I'm scared of them
I figured like an animal that I don't like
would be the perfect pet for uh
the Pewdiepie channel
He's really cool
I really like him
Alright,
well Slippy's now a member of the family, Ainsley
rest his soul
I hope he doesn't get too big
Let's show some footage of like how big they can get
Also if you lick Slippy
I have to wash my hands now cause he's venomous
So if you lick- if I wanna, you know get that poodiepie on,
Just lick him.
[Camera Man 1]: He's venomous?
[Camera Man 2]: As in poisonous or hallucinogen?
Hallucinogen.
Really? Yeah you could- we're gonna have a party tonight
[All]: *laughter*
Do you guys like the name Slippy?
So I thought Slippy would just be like, the coolest
most original idea for a frog [toad]
No one else has ever named their frog [toad] Slippy.
So I just thought it would be like a really cool original idea.
Why do you have a skull in there?
Cause Slippy is a warlock!
Oh
*ha ha ha*
We'll get a better house for him
And he'll get more accustomed
and Slippy will hopefully live a long happy life together with Felix and friends!
*catchy music*
Alright, well thanks for, watching.
Uh... Leave a... like for all the toads in the world.
Now I will...
Brofist!
*pewds looks around*
*Thumbs up!!*
*catchy end music*
#RIPSLIPPY